le hockey québécois n'a pas fondé
d'espoir sur un tel attaquant au
repêchage depuis plus de deux décennies
un bon joueur devenu fabricant de jeu
exceptionnel champion compteur bantam
midget et bientôt de la ligue de hockey
junior majeur du québec
alexis la fronière c'est le joueur par
excellence du dernier championnat du
monde puisque j'ai vécu un noël c'était
vraiment des très bons moments puis se
fait des rêves d'enfance qui devient
réalité
le capitaine de l'océanic fait aussi
rêver
v toutes les équipes de la ligue
nationale de chaque équipe du national
veut rencontre alexis en vue du prochain
repêchage qui est à montréal
ça fait beaucoup beaucoup de monde
autour qui veulent le rencontrer qui
veulent essayer de voir s'il ya des
choses qu'il faut qu'il faut savoir qu
on s'épaule
l'uci a focus sur les bonnes choses
c'est que je lève mon chapeau pour seul
existe un exceptionnel
écoutez les pollens catégorique personne
ici une renommée déjà assez forte pour
pousser ce garçon de 11 ans a suggéré à
son professeur à l'école de préparer un
exposé oral sur alexis mais le faire à
l'arena devant son idole
après le match est plus jeune et fait un
exposé rassure toi mon école c'est que
je parlais que commente m'inspirer
c'est trop fâché avec moi tu vois un
autre visage que toutes les autres
joueurs dans les faits que sur ce qu'est
ce qu'un membre comics book ou the
malgrave un honneur pour moi que j'ai ce
paquet en exposera a bien été de telles
rencontres nathalie louis les vives avec
alexis sa famille d'accueil a appris à
découvrir la personnalité de ce jeune
homme discret de cette tâche s'attachera
après trois aux arabi avec nous autres
c'est comme les garçons aujourd'hui
au square espoir aux jeunes
mais lisbonne ne reviennent plus
[Musique]
comme sidney crosby et vincent
lecavalier qui ont aussi joué avec
l'océanic alexis la fronière devrait
être le premier joueur sélectionné la
séance de repêchage de la lnh bressan
lecavalier par timidité et se décroisent
ou par concentration était beaucoup plus
sérieux entre guillemets qu alex la fin
des repas sur les cinq ne travaille pas
sur la patinoire
les saint alexis d'affreux nains il a
toujours le sourire aux lèvres lui à
bâle a vu du bon côté
[Applaudissements]
c'est une équipe qui joue et donné une
couverture médiatique et france mène
maintenant 3 ans rimouski c'est la ville
de hakki junior au pays où les amateurs
de rock lire à seulement 25 ans ont eu
la chance inouïe d'applaudir de joueur
le plus prometteur au monde trois fois
16 à 17 ans et jean françois poirier
radio canada à rimouski
ce concours s'est acharné
[Musique]